hello my name is Hank green in early
2008 my brother helped me kill a man we
have blood on our hands
[Music]
dead I killed him dead dead with a knife
okay not actually with a knife I killed
a man with YouTube okay not just me my
brother and I I have killed him and John
Green have killed him we've killed a man
who is this person well uh let me show
you blood brothers videos have been
viewed on YouTube eleven million times
11 million in each one of our videos are
3 point 7 minutes long that's forty
point seven million minutes divided by
sixty that's six hundred and seventy
eight thousand hours do you see where
I'm going with this yet divided by 24
divided by 365
that's seventy seven point four years
seventy seven point four years divided
by the lifespan of one human is 1/2
blood on my head I killed a man with
YouTube videos it occurs to me that if I
have been making YouTube videos during
the 15th century I would have killed two
people already now if we take this more
literally this was a very long death
it took John and I a long time to kill
this guy additionally if we're being
literal it wasn't a guy is probably
mostly a girl but definitely a part boy
and girl I've been curious for some time
on the demographics the girls like the
vlogbrothers better than boys um very
curious but here's how we can figure
that out just leave your gender in the
comments informal demographic another
ssassaror girl girl boy girl girl that
will be exciting for us because then
we'll know what kind of person we killed
if it's like 75 percent girl or if it's
50 percent girl 50 percent boy I want to
know what kind of person I killed
blood on my hands seriously though for
some reason I think that this is
actually important I killed a man with
YouTube I don't feel bad but why don't I
feel bad do I in fact feel that you
right now watching my video are not
wasting time yes I do this is not
wasting time in fact all of this talk
about killing hypothetical people have
made me start to think about the big
Slayers of hypothetical people we have
to spend their time doing something and
there are a lot of things that are not
worth our time that we do spend lots of
time doing I am fascinated that our
videos have been reviewed so many times
but I've done some calculations and it
turns out that killing one hypothetical
person not really that big of a deal
every year pooping kills about 14,000
hypothetical people 14,000 times 77
years pooping every year in America and
what you should be doing is watching us
while you poop multitasking every time
the Super Bowl comes around once a year
it eats up more than 150 lives
interestingly according to a video I
just watched people have spent about
that much time making Wikipedia the
largest collection of knowledge in the
universe was created in the same amount
of time that it takes for 100 million
Americans to watch the Superbowl Cola I
don't understand so the point I want to
get across here is that we can choose
what to do with our time now instead of
spending it passively eating up all the
information that the media companies get
possible to get us can actually be part
of it so we need to be searching for
it's pretty easy to find nowadays and
ways to communicate and participate and
create because we have time and I know
that YouTube provides this and the
Internet in general but I also like the
hope that we provide that something that
we do together not something that you do
the asar that we do to you something
that we do together I think that's what
this is and I don't think that's a waste
of time nerdfighters so thank you for
your life however little small chunks
you wish to give us we will take them
and we will give ours to you as well
thank you
blood how's that very good boy your girl